bonjour merci d'être heures direct avec
nos sur rt france le mouvement du 5 juin
qui réclament la démission du président
ibrahim boubacar keïta a donc finalement
un choisi d'annuler le rassemblement
auquel il avait appelé pour hier on le
sait une mission de médiation de la
cedeao est arrivé mercredi dans le pays
est ce que c'est à elle qu'on doit cette
pause j'ai pas bien compris votre que
votre question est est-ce que selon vous
le rôle joué par la cedeao qui est
arrivé au mali mercredi est ce que son
rôle a entraîné très concrètement à une
pause dans les tensions notamment
concernant le mouvement du 5 juin qui
finalement est revenu sur son appel à la
manifestation hier
oui bien sûr au moins il a eu un
vendredi aura pas de manifestation mais
je ne pense pas que ça va et nous c'est
vraiment la détermination des mariannes
on connaît ce peuple qui depuis les
indépendances afin de partir à
l'exception de un seul président alpha
oumar konaré a fait partir tous ses
présidents
ça te par un coup d'état ou les
mouvements de rue donc je pense que ça
va permettre de faire baisser un peu la
tension et de reprendre les négociations
peut-être même une reprise de
négociations la reprise de négociations
et pour les contestataires n'est lié au
départ maintenant de ib kabaha ibrahim
boubacar keita
parce que eux veulent que ib cas et des
pouvoirs réduits alors que ib cave
conserver la plénitude de son pouvoir et
mettre en place un gouvernement d'union
nationale qui n'intéressent pas les
contestataires et pour quelle raison ne
veulent t'ils pas justement ce
gouvernement d'union nationale selon
vous ce pourrait être la solution
un gouvernement d'union nationale mais
on en a souvent eu au mali est ce que
c'est vraiment la solution face au grave
crise de corruption que dénoncent aussi
les contestataires
est ce que c'est
c'est l'absolution par rapport au fait
qu' ils ont demandé que les résultats
des élections législatives de mars soit
ce que soient reconnus se prononcer
provisoirement par le ministère de
l'intérieur et non pas par la cour
constitutionnelle qui a tardé aussi être
démis de ses fonctions vu les tensions
finalement des mimes m tout cela ne
suffit pas aux contestataires qu'ils
veulent vraiment une situation
irréversible
un nettoyage total et que cela n'arrange
vraiment pas le président de la
république parce que ça va avoir un jour
ses pouvoirs et ils demandent également
la dissolution de l'assemblée qui une
fois que le président n'a pas la
majorité à l'assemblée ça va le
fragiliser et peut-être précipité sa
chute
autrement donc tout ça et des ce sont
des choses à mettre sur une balance et à
pouvoir supposé même la cedeao qui reste
constitutionnaliste et et légaliste
souvent arrive comme au togo à un phare
maintenir les pouvoirs en place qui sont
en tenant compte de la constitution mais
bon on verra bien nous mais je sais que
souvent le peuple malien est déterminé
et les tensions sont très vivant dans le
pays depuis les résultats contestés des
élections législatives de mars à avril
des manifestations émaillées de
violences ces derniers jours à vous
entendre on est largement au delà d'une
simple crise post électorale
oui mais la crise est d'abord lié au
fait que selon les contestataires que le
président de la république n'a pas pu
gérer la crise au nord la crise
sanitaire et la corruption
donc à cela s'est ajouté les photos les
images de son fils qui a démissionné de
la présence de la commission défense de
l'assemblée mais qui n'intéresse plus
apparemment les les contestataires qui
veulent tout simplement le départ de
ibrahim boubacar keita mais qui sera
difficile parce que
vu le nombre de morts qui a eu je pense
que ça va déterminer de plus amples et
les contestataires parce que on les
entend sur les réseaux sociaux disent
que oci bk qui va partir ou ils les
tuent tous donc le slogan c'est où ils
nous tuent tous où il s'en va je pense
que yahoo aujourd'hui à une
manifestation à paris devant l'ambassade
qui à être le même slogan
voilà merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le
temps de répondre à nos questions sadio
morales a compté journaliste et
spécialiste de l'afrique